nachts retten sie Lebensmittel aus dem
supermarktmüll und verstossen dabei
gegen das Gesetz die Aktivisten machen
es trotzdem
wenn dann doch mal jemand von
irgendeinem Sicherheitsdienst kommt oder
neue wahre geliefert wird nachts das ist
dann schon immer noch wieder so eine
Schrecksekunde wollen
Berge von Lebensmitteln landen jedes
Jahr in der Tonne retten verboten
JayJay Link zeigt uns die Ausbeute von
letzter Nacht Milchprodukte kiloweise
Obst und Gemüse alles aus dem Müll
das ist einfach ein Platz wo keine
Lebensmittel sein sollten Punkt aus die
Lebensmittel die wurden produziert da
wurden Ressourcen reingesteckt Wasser
Sprit Energie und ich finde das ist
falsch ist die weg zu werfen erstmal
wird das gerettete Essen sortiert und
gewaschen
aber den Zitronen oft ist es dann so das
eine schimmelt aus dem Netz diesmal ist
die schimmlige nicht dabei oder ich weiß
nicht ob es das halt rausgeflogen ist
oft reichen kleine Makel und
Lebensmittel landen in der Tonne diese
Eier sehen zwar ramponiert aus aber
kaputt
noch ganz unten noch mindestens zwei
Wochen haltbar sie aus dem Müll zu
nehmen ist trotzdem nicht erlaubt
Diebstahl und damit strafbar der
bundeslandwirtschaftsminister will das
ändern appelliert an die Länder das
Containern künftig nicht mehr zu
bestrafen
was wir hier machen Marco Buschmann die
Justizminister und ich als
bundeslandwirtschaftsminister ist keine
Aufforderung zu Straftaten es ist keine
Aufforderung irgendwas zu zerstören
Schlösser zu knacken so das geht hier um
Tonnen die offen zugänglich sind wer
dort Lebensmittel entnimmt die
verzehrfähig sind soll dafür nicht für
Diebstahl angezeigt werden jedes Jahr
entstehen in Deutschland etwa 11
Millionen Tonnen Lebensmittelabfälle
laut Statistischem Bundesamt fallen
davon etwa 7% auf den Handel der
Großteil etwa 59% werde aber in privaten
Haushalten weggeworfen wir treffen
Baden-Württembergs ernährungsminister
bisherige Versuche das Containern zu
entkriminalisieren scheiterten an seiner
CDU
Peter Hauck sieht weiterhin keinen
Änderungsbedarf will dafür bei den
Privathaushalten ansetzen sein Vorschlag
dass Mindesthaltbarkeitsdatum abschaffen
gerade jüngere Verbraucher das wissen
wir aus Umfragen
werfen unbesehen vom Zustand des
Lebensmittel nach Ablauf des
Mindesthaltbarkeitsdatum des
Lebensmittel einfach weg das wäre doch
gut genießbar und deshalb glaube ich
macht es keinen Sinn ein MHD so zu
konzipieren eine Alternative sei zum
Beispiel der Aufdruck des
Produktionsdatums der Bundesverband des
deutschen Lebensmittelhandels will davon
nichts wissen um die Qualität eines
Produkts zu beurteilen brauche der Kunde
das Haltbarkeitsdatum und das Containern
ist dazu da Lebensmittel zu entsorgen
das heißt es ist kein Ort unter dem man
unter hygienischen und
lebensmittelrechtlichen Bedingungen
Lebensmittel aufbewahrt sondern um sie
wegzuschwerfen oder beziehungsweise sie
zu entsorgen das heißt allein schon aus
der Tat sie heraus bilden sich natürlich
in lebensmittelabfalltonnen Keime ja die
auf andere Lebensmittel übergehen können
da haben außerdem gehe das Containern
fast immer mit anderen Straftaten einher
die Tonnen im Lebensmittelhandel sind
entweder verschlossen oder hinter Zäunen
aufbewahrt das bedeutet wenn man dort
eindringt begeht man Hausfriedensbruch
bzw schwere Sachbeschädigung das möchte
der Minister ja auch nicht insofern
brauchen wir diesen Vorschlag nicht weil
er nicht hilft diese Einschätzung geht
für JJ Link an der Realität vorbei viele
Supermarkt Tonnen seien frei zugänglich
und teils randvoll mit verwertbaren
Lebensmitteln
manches Lande aber zu Recht im Müll
überwachen Rückrufe zum Beispiel
informiert sich JJ online
formverzehr am Produkt riechen oder mal
probieren gehört auch dazu
also ist schon auch ganz schön viel
Wissen über Lebensmittel mit dabei wenn
man sich von Lebensmitteln sicher
ernähren möchte dann ist es gut man weiß
ein bisschen was drüber fast jedes
Produkt findet sich irgendwann im
Supermarkt Müll einkaufen geht JJ daher
kaum noch aber wenn ich dann mal
einkaufen gehe dann beobachte ich immer
so die anderen Leute auch und sie dann
immer so wie sie an der Banane schon
eine kleine braune Stelle lieber nicht
kaufen und ich habe inzwischen einen ja
gerade dem entgegengehen das
Einkaufsverhalten entwickelt wenn ich
eine Paprika sehe die eine kleine Macke
dann versuche ich die zu kaufen damit
sie nicht im Müll landet der Großteil
von dem was hier gekocht wird lag aber
schon mal im Müll und alles kann JayJay
bei weitem nicht selbst essen über eine
messenger-gruppe gibt es Infos was man
heute abholen kann nach nicht mal 10
Minuten klingelt es
dass so viel weggeworfen wird ist für
viele erschreckend selbst zu Containern
aber kostet Überwindung
selbst wenn ich erwischt würde dann also
man kann es ja auch nutzen um die
Öffentlichkeit zu informieren die
bundesweite Debatte über das Containern
finden JayJay und Mitbewohnerin Ina gut
aber
natürlich ist es ein guter Schritt in
die richtige Richtung aber im Endeffekt
muss es ja viel weiter gehen also der
schon gar nicht erst so weit kommen dass
die Sachen trotzdem in der Tonne landen
sondern eigentlich könnte man sich schon
viel früher an Menschen weitergeben
Ina Schumann ist ehrenamtliche
Stadträtin zwei Jahre hat sie dafür
gekämpft dass Stuttgart offiziell
foodsharing statt wird ein Symbol der
Partnerschaft zwischen Stadt und der
bundesweiten Initiative gegen
Lebensmittelverschwendung
durch diese Unterzeichnung dieser food
Challenge statt Erklärung haben wir
natürlich jetzt auch ganz andere
Argumente zu sagen liebe Stadtverwaltung
wir möchten auch dass ihr noch
weitergeht dass ihr vielleicht auch
eigene Verteiler bereitstellt im
Tübinger Rathaus gibt es einen solchen
städtischen Verteiler schon Nina Dauer
und Sophia Häussler bringen ausrangierte
Lebensmittel aus einem Supermarkt Obst
Gemüse und Backwaren
Bücherschrank für Lebensmittel das heißt
jeder kann Lebensmittel hinbringen und
jeder kann auch Lebensmittel wieder
rausnehmen und natürlich gibt es da so
ein paar Regeln die sind man sieht man
auch hier die man beachten muss also was
da rein was darf nicht rein besonders
empfindliche Lebensmittel dürfen dann
natürlich nicht rein Fleisch roher
Fischprodukte irgendwelche Sahnetorten
foodsharing kooperiert mit Supermärkten
Bäckern und anderen Betrieben rettet
Lebensmittel die sonst in der Tonne
landen würden die Tafeln haben dabei
übrigens immer Vorrang foodsharing holt
ab was darüber hinaus übrig bleibt dabei
haftet jeder einzelne lebensmittelretter
für das was er oder sie in den Verteiler
legt im Moment gibt es einige rechtliche
Hürden für Lebensmittel rettende
Organisationen und auch Haftungsrisiken
und es gibt gute Beispiele aus anderen
Ländern wie zum Beispiel in Italien das
Gute Samariter Gesetz des Lebens die
Rettungsorganisation rechtlich als
Endverbraucher einstuft und damit werden
viele rechtliche Hürden und auch Risiken
für die lebensmittelretter abgebaut über
1.000 solche Verteiler gibt es in der
Bundesrepublik einen davon in
Deutschlands erstem foodsharing-café
Raupe immer satt in Stuttgart
bevor sie in der verteilstation landen
werden die geretteten Lebensmittel vom
café-team überprüft und vorsortiert das
sind jetzt Lebensmittel die wir von
Supermarkt eben erhalten haben die dort
eben übrig waren und die vielleicht
irgendwie eine braune Stelle haben bei
dem Apfel jetzt oder die Karotte ist ein
bisschen krumm gewachsen und der
Supermarkt hat sich eben entschieden das
auszusortieren und nicht mehr zu
verkaufen aber hat immerhin ein
foodsharing gespendet und nicht in die
Tonne geworfen mit gespendetem Essen
machen sie keinen Profit alles im
Verteiler ist kostenlos genau wie das
selbstgemachte Bananenbrot gebacken aus
geretteten Zutaten
bei Kaffee und anderen Getränken setzt
das Team auf ein solidarisches Konzept
jeder Gast zahlt so viel wie er kann und
möchte
weil ja eben in unserer Gesellschaft
nicht alle Leute gleich viel Geld haben
und wir niemanden aufgrund eines Preises
ausschließen wollen das heißt alle
können hier eben teilhaben und man zahlt
nach den eigenen Möglichkeiten und nach
der Frage was ist einem Wert ist was
sind Lebensmittel Wert mit dieser Frage
kann man sich in der Raupe immer satt
ganz nebenbei auseinandersetzen aber
foodsharing und Containern das ändere
nichts am grundsätzlichen Problem
solange für Lebensmittelbetriebe
lukrativ ist billig zu produzieren und
zu verkaufen und auch die Verschwendung
schon mit Einzug kalkulieren
glauben wir dass ich daran nicht sehr
viel ändern wird auch für der Link geht
es beim Thema Lebensmittelverschwendung
letztlich um Wertschätzung
das ist auch ein bisschen die Frage als
was sieht man die Lebensmitteln denn an
als
wirtschaftsware oder ist es irgendwie
was woran halt auch ethische Werte
hängen und ich finde wenn jemand
Lebensmittel hat
auch wenn wenn man sein Geld damit
verdient hat mir trotzdem irgendwie die
Verpflichtung die nicht einfach so
vernichten zu lassen sondern sie
irgendwie weiterzugeben obwohl viele
Supermärkte freiwillig mit den Tafeln
oder foodsharing zusammenarbeiten landen
immer noch Berge von Lebensmitteln im
Müll
JayJay möchte das nicht mit ansehen
am liebsten werden einfach im Müll keine
Sachen liegen und ich mir nicht Gedanken
machen müsste ob die weggeworfen werden
damit ich auch für liebend gern wieder
einkaufen gehen solange aber wird JJ
wohl weitermachen und Lebensmittel aus
supermarkttonnen retten